okay for people who are joining this
live stream this is a continuation of
our discussion of
multi-computation and extending our
whole computational framework to think
about multi-computation and we've got
multiple different things to study in
terms of multi-computation
um we had been actually yesterday in a
different meeting discussing
the generalization of our find equation
or proof technology
um i want to let me just try to to
make several different buckets that i
wanted to make sure we talked about
today
um
i want to talk about okay so just as a
sort of proto thing i want to talk about
uh
supplied whose name i don't really like
very much i haven't that hasn't grown on
me since yesterday
um i want to talk about that i want to
talk about infinite lists
i want to talk about uh representation
of um
uh of proofs
and
general tracing of computations
those are topics there
let's um
save this away here
uh
okay so actually one first thing this is
a point uh from sander
by email
um sander points out the very obvious
issue
of when we have so let's let's start off
talking about supplied here
that when we are doing a map with a
supplied
and there is a map within that
there's a question of which
uh
let's see how does it work here um
there's there's the question
just like variables inside a map just
like if you have a um
a map
where you have you know hash plus map
blah blah blah
and the question is which which hash are
you picking up and it's always the
innermost hash that you get
uh at any given um well not in that case
because i didn't have another ampersand
but um the question is
for
supplied are people understanding the
issue
i mean let me pull up um
send us
example here
um
okay what is this so this is
i see so the issue there is within that
supplied
if it has a hash index
that is presumably getting the hash
index
of
from the map
and sandra asks the question which i
think is going to get kind of messy
about scoping of this and
is there a way
to reference the outer index here how
would you reference
in this kind of setup how would you
reference the outer index
so i think that the
long winded way of writing it would be
uh for the outer
supply you'd have to have an outer
supplied for sure
yeah and then
and then one way you could do it is that
inside that our supplied to use function
right and you give it a name in that
case it would give you the whole
association
and probably you'd have to do
excuse me just to make it you know
better performance and things would be
to also give it a first argument to
supplied
yep to specify which keys you want
okay yeah
and then and then here
well i don't want it but now you have to
say x comma i or something
right you're gonna get two arguments
okay
and then
in this case that is the okay so then
here i can say i plus index for example
yes
and don't forget when you the inner map
of course has to be mapping over you
and a map
oh assuming that's oh never mind i i
thought you were doing something
slightly different yeah okay fine fine
okay so that's the inner map
and that closes the function
and the supplied has that function
inside and that's the table
that's not grotesque i mean it's the
same as what's applied even
in table like table doesn't take a
function
maybe it works an array
yeah well right but but the thing is we
want supplied to work in rules in
particular
so that's a good question should supply
work in table it would be nice if it did
you know monitor works and table
well so my question is should supplied
be specifically for functions or do we
want it also for rules and maybe other
things well that's a good question i
mean supplied in
table
uh rule etc i mean we want something
like it in all those places because i
strongly think that table doesn't make
sense
because you say you've already got the
variable
well you've already got the variable and
you and the reason module works or
monitor works is just because it's it's
you know picking up the variable it's
picking up the variable it's just
because tables block basically but but i
think that
like
for example with rule you can even you
can at least make an argument that well
the right hand side of your rule delayed
or something is a little bit like the
right-hand side of a set delayed in a
function and so you know
it's it's at least like the syntax is is
basically the same
but uh in a table
there's no function anywhere like
there's no
yeah i mean there's no
yeah so certainly array but not table so
you're saying
replace this by an array
and now
this thing here becomes
right so now the u you do range of u
inside and then on the outside you just
do range of ten
right
right
okay
yeah just 10 right because it's just the
array
thing
um
okay okay
so
how does this does this potentially
solve the problem of monitor inside map
the supplied thing
so
it gets kind of reversed like the
progress indicator
would use
supplied for its implementation
i see
so but then so does that mean
monitor of map
you know because what we've wanted it to
do is to just be able to say monitor a
map without a variable
that making sense
does this provide an implementation for
that
not as such but for things like fraction
complete
yeah but how would that work i mean
is that can you can you see how i'm
confused are you asking how how are we
going to implement the progress
reporting for maps are you talking about
yes that would be that would be i mean i
feel like that's going to be a lower
level thing i mean i think if we did it
in the top level using something like
supplied it would probably probably be a
performance impact no i understand but
can we at least conceptually see how it
would work with supply
well i mean one thing you could do is
just have
i mean i guess you do monitor you do
module or like this is what the monitor
would kind of turn into right it would
be module of you know
progress or something fraction something
like that and then you have um
inside you have map
of uh
right supplied and then you want to get
the value and then you want to get the
fraction complete
okay or it would be like index
and then you would use the index from
the outside to build a uh
well let's say we've got fractions
complete let's imagine that
yeah don't know that you would have
fraction complete in supplied
so much i think we calculate the
fraction complete
using
supplements we've been talking about
having that as a possible key fraction
complete so let's just assume we have
fraction complete as a key yeah in the
worst case it's not hard to compute
yourself but yeah so so you just say
supplied and then you'd say quotes
fraction complete right there
oh quote
well actually i guess you could write it
you could you could write it like this
actually if you want to use yes you'd
say you know progress equals fraction
complete
semicolon
uh
you know semicolon f of
hash expression and then of course
you're going to need parentheses in
ampersand
and then
inside the module but outside the map
you'd write a monitor
right
there you'd monitor the progress you'd
monitor the assignment of progress
yes
right
makes sense
yeah
okay so look i think even though
supplied is not a name that's been
sitting well with me um
it sounds like ian thinks uh i mean ian
is pursuing this is that a fair
statement
yeah i can come up with like a list of
keys for
structural and
tree type
operations
good and functions that they should go
into and then we have to start thinking
about how the actual implementation
works
and whether we can do a at least an
initial implementation without values
and so on
okay topic two if we've i mean this is
already an exciting topic and uh okay
actually the the
another issue is
how to deliver
structured
uh sort of supplied material
so this is what we talked about before
you're deep in a computation
you are
throwing
uh sort of information about what's
happening in the computation
it's like like
aka
modern trace
okay so remember we're you you're
iterating through a computation you're
you're or recursing through a
computation you know and we've remember
we've got these two different forms of
of progress in a computation one is
recursion through the spatial structure
of an expression tree the other is
essentially time-like recursion of
reevaluation of things
right so it's like spatial recursion
and
uh and temporal time-like recursion
and
this is both are throwing up
results okay so the question is what how
do those results land what do they land
in and that brings us across here to
this equation or proof thing i think
does this make any sense to people i
mean we're trying to say you're doing a
computation and things are happening and
you want to record what did you do in
the computation
anybody understand what i'm talking
about anybody want to try re-explaining
that in a different way
is it's like
the difference between fold and fold
list maybe
like bold you're just getting the final
value fold list you're showing the steps
along yes that's that's a good that's a
good point very generally
right right right right right okay right
that's a good way to think about it what
is the general version
of quotes nest list
as opposed to
the evaluator the main evaluator
which just gives
the result of nest
okay so that let's take an analogy here
a full simplified versus find equational
proof
so full simplified just tells you
yes this result is true
but find equational proof shows you the
steps that got there
okay or in particular
in
you know if you have something which
eventually reach reaches a fixed point
my okay i think i decided slightly here
so trace already
separates these two types of recursion
but one is different elements in a list
the other one is
nesting of lists
now the thing that trace doesn't give
you that find the question or proof does
is what got applied so that you arrived
at this new expression
you just get the new expression but you
don't know how or why that's correct
right and in this picture i find
equational proof these events here
are this shows you the new expression
and this event shows you is the thing
is the melting pot that took the
existing expressions and turned it into
the new expression
right
and then this yeah
sorry in trace we already have the
sequence of what happened
fair enough
yes okay so
trace
gives sequences of results
and
and a skeleton
of
quote spatial recursion
just in a list right is that right yes i
would argue that also the time like
precaution
but that's its sequence of results right
so let's let's do an example can we do
an example how can we do an example of
trace um let's see how would we do this
we would say
um well let's just do something here we
say nest
fx3
do some mathematical operation that that
gets recomputing something
how would i do that can i do one plus
one plus one plus one or is that also
going to be trivial
how do i do something that's
non-trivial maybe i can do the um
maybe i can create
what could i do i could do a fold list
of f
and then i could do table
of one comma
six for example
can you define for perhaps uh one of
these factorial definitions and then we
evaluate it
okay what would happen in this case what
would happen here if i take this thing
here
and i say
uh
trace of that slash dot f goes to plus
that gonna be interesting
yeah that is mildly interesting right
look at that sequence there
yes but here we have also the nesting
which i think is the interesting part
what you call time like precaution
is this time like recursion well perhaps
i'm confused with parentheses it's very
small
okay but hold on i can make it bigger
that's a problem that's easy to solve
relative to all of the ones we have
yep
big set of nested lists where
yeah
yeah what am i seeing there
so one plus one evaluates to two
that expression evaluates to two plus
one
and then but then no but then we're
using this is some kind of weird space
time thing because then we're using the
outer plus one is being introduced so
the
sequential thing is an expression got
re-evaluated
and the nested lists are sub-expressions
got evaluated
i understand but how do we do a pure
the same expression got re-evaluated
many times is there a way to do that to
see that in price
um
that is this okay so let's say trace
and then let's say
i see
i equals one
do i equals
i plus one uh
you know this hasn't been modernized
since we changed the syntax for for
trace for do
okay there we go
oh my gosh can anybody explain to me
what the heck is going on here
what's the first element
it's hard to tell with the line breaking
uh well let's let's
say column of that
fine
let's do this let's start right over
here
okay
actually you know what let's do this
let's map framed
onto every level that is a list
okay
map if head of hash
triple equals list framed of hash
otherwise hash
and then let's do that
let's do a map all
of that onto the trace
you should use your replacement you
should use replace with level spec 0 to
infinity
well i think the real problem is
if head
you're mapping into a hold form
ultimately at some point yeah i know it
really doesn't matter what you write one
comma zero
the if isn't evaluating because it's
inside of a hold form oh it doesn't
matter what you write there just use
replace just use your place and just say
replace and then your trace
replace all no replace because you need
to do from zero to infinity because
otherwise it'll only do the outermost
level
okay so what do i do here if hash get
rid of the f just just do the trace that
that is the first argument and the
second argument
oh i see i see i see what you can do oh
yeah okay yeah
okay trace of that comma
list
underscore you know l underscore list
goes to frame devel
and then from zero to infinity yeah
okay that's helpful
there's some misfires though i think
what do you mean
like the do the second argument of the
do
er no sorry never mind
yeah that i mean that's correctly a list
although it's a list
of a different origin
yeah
because we're because we're basically
reusing lists here
yeah
um avery points out that there's a
resource function called um
trace print evaluations
that
i i'd forgotten trace print
um
what
oh my gosh what is this
this stuff is also obscure we have got
to demystify all this stuff
what does trace print go ahead sorry i
think this is this type of example in
which we have a function which is
recursive is a better example because
you see the the re-evaluation
okay all right so just let's copy this
definition and do trace of something
here
i just have to remember to clear to use
a
kill off my session after to find all
the single letter names okay
so now you say
let's do the same deal here just so we
can see
where everything is of trace of
uh
f of 4 or something
oh my gosh
what are we seeing here
so f 4 is replaced with f of four minus
one plus f of four minus two that's but
i understand yeah
actually it has to go inside and
evaluate each of them so it opens a new
level of list
and it evaluates f of 4 minus 1 and f of
4 minus 2 which get combined at the very
end you see the 2 plus 1 comma 3.
yep
okay but if i say trace f of 4
comma f
i'll see only the f evaluations
and that's that thing that i'm seeing
here will have the structure of a tree
correct
so if i this is a fibonacci tree is it
not
can i make that into an actual tree
somehow
i will add a structure to expression
tree for it
you'd have to write you'd have to use
nest tree
okay but i mean actually
i'll i'll try to come up with an example
real quick
okay perhaps expression three of
sub-expressions
there's no auto-complete by the way
here i'm complaining about auto complete
maybe avery can make a note of that
oh again the whole forms yeah and
complicate the thing yeah
right so we need a special type to
eliminate all the whole form stuff
maybe we need a held sub-expressions for
expression tree
there is a held sub-expressions
but it's still going to have all those
whole forms in there
i see
and by the way your printing should not
have the printing of the explicit hold
forms in it
i mean that's just a
that's just the symbol hold form
oh oh gosh
okay all right okay but anyway let's
look at this here so this is now a
fibonacci tree but but how do i see
and you're saying that
everything in the sequence here
is what i'm calling a
my god this is confusing i am so
confused by all the stuff
okay if we take this
and we say trace of that
what is going on here you're saying
this sequence
where is my kind of time like evaluation
sequence
so time like is like f of 4 minus 1 is
that next box that you see with the
whole
f of three all of that
i see that's everything involved in
computing f of four minus one and then
the next one's everything involved in
computing f four minus two
question for physics project
people what is the relationship of these
relations and causal graphs and causal
relations
you know it seems like we've got
our
i'm quite confused here but is there is
there some obvious way in which there is
a
okay could we draw this as a graph first
question could this naturally be drawn
as a graph
because you know when we built
trace in version two time frame
um
you know we were
you know it was long before we had
graphs so were we to do this today would
we end up with something more like this
graph to represent what's going on
what is the evaluation graph basically
is my question
and it seems like what um
seems like what we have here
okay can somebody see what would be the
natural i mean the natural evaluation
graph here i think i drew some recently
is
it's just this
fibonacci it's more or less a fibonacci
tree in this case
um
everybody's silent
is that because everybody's confused or
or can i make a comment yeah please
yeah so um at least from my vantage
point it seems like the obvious way to
represent this
you know as a as a post set
or something
is to say this you know this nesting is
you know
that's the those correspond to the
actual like time-like edges in some in
some hassa diagram right
and the locations where individual rules
get applied which you know in the fine
equation or proof
you know uh case is just literally a
part specification those are then split
up into individual sub-expressions that
lie on you know potentially on one
anti-chain
okay let's let's let's un-parse this for
a second or parse this somehow
what you're distinguishing here
you know you're describing it as
post-set which is of course correct so
there are okay first point there are
things on anti-change there are things
that can be evaluated simultaneously
well in principle i mean if if i say
something like one plus one
comma two plus two
one plus one and two plus two live on an
anti-chain
because they are in principle
separately valuable
do we do we agree i mean that that's the
kind of thing you mean is that right
right right but the the point is that
the thing that you're referring to is
you know space like separation or
something which you know is in in fine
equation or proof is just literally the
past expression the the part
specification of what sub-expression had
a transformation applied to it
those you know if those um
sub-expressions don't overlap then kind
of by definition
it doesn't matter what what order you
evaluate them in right yes
so there's a natural representation of
this thing as a partially ordered set
where each individual non-overlapping
sub-expression is treated as a separate
element of the anti-chain and that the
the actual order structure is showing
you the recursion you know the time-like
recursion depth the nesting
okay but hold on the very fact look
there's one question given a piece of
code
and this is a question that we're
interested in for other reasons given a
piece of code can it be evaluated in a
multi-threaded fashion where different
things are happening on different
threads independent of each other
and that is essentially the anti-chain
question
is it not
right right and so like the you know if
you take something like this
you've got
uh you know
in this case the individual
sub-expressions to which you know in
this case combinator reductions are
being applied are literally represented
as anti-chains
okay now we have to understand this
um
this may not be the ideal example it's
just a something to indicate what i mean
okay all right so let's let's
do people understand okay just just to
make sure everybody's on the same page
in terms of what we're talking about
here
so
among our objectives
is to be able to understand so a
sub-objective
you know
what can in principle
be evaluated on the evaluation on a
parallel thread
in parallel
aka uh
what is on an anti-chain
in
the
quotes evaluation post set is it an
evaluation post set
in other words is the
what i'm confused by is the spatial
aspect of evaluation that is the
different parts of expressions
is is this i think
okay
that's my question is it is it the case
that
so i mean
coming back to the expression you just
have there this three so for example we
have the f4
and the f4 happens to evaluate to a sum
of two things
so now you have to evaluate those two
things separately and that's why you
have now two lists following each one
evaluating one of them so i think those
are your threads
your space yes that's correct those two
things can be two separate threads
right although although it wouldn't be
in this particular case
confusingly because of shared common
sub-expressions
it would actually be a mistake to
evaluate those well i i don't know if
it's a mistake it will be
that there is a fast way to evaluate
this that does breadth first traversal
rather than
evaluating all the way down to the
leaves
separately on each thread
that's a confusing case
that makes sense in other words
fibonacci if i were to do
if i were to go another level here
and say you know f of five
as the classic case where breadth first
evaluation is useful f of five goes f
this goes to this
and that then goes to
you know f of
four plus f of three
plus
uh
f of three plus f of two
and now of course if we're doing it
breadth first
we can combine those two together and so
we no longer have an exponential number
of terms
right but we don't get to do that if
we're splitting it
in this evaluation graph so this is
this is part of you know daggification
so to speak
but
i think trace is being faithful to
what's happening if we had defined the
function f with memoization i i know
yeah i know i know it's it's being
faithful to our evaluation
traversal order yes it is it is trace is
a is a single way system trace is not
showing us
so there is a multi-way version of this
that
can be well let's see that can be
traversed differently but that's not
what this is showing us but anyway keep
keep going you would say i agree with
you that every box here can be evaluated
on a separate thread
right so so i think the the time
sequence is the horizontal thing and
then the spatial bifurcation is what
triggers the the nesting of nest things
yes i think that's right
now just just for some additional
context maybe somebody uh i mean at
least they have the right net let's see
richard posted something about um
uh trace functions in
boy
okay
and and there's also another thing that
uh we're certainly
aware of called tracelets which i think
might be related which i'm sure jonathan
knows about at least which i don't know
about but they seem to have a good name
at least
um
the uh
let's see okay
there's also a highly related notion of
lenses in functional programming um that
may be with
what are those i don't know what those
are
okay but so so we've got tracelets we've
got lenses
we've got and now we've got local
multi-way systems
and we've meanwhile got
the general question of what does our
what is a graph
you know
what is the evaluation graph
how do we represent you know and
you know in a sense
this
is the evaluation graph of
the
proof function
of find equational proof is that a true
statement
well no i mean and this is the point
that i'm trying to make about the about
global multi-way systems
so if you take something like this say
it's pretty obvious that substitution
number one and substitution number two
lie on an anti-chain
okay so here's a proof and now what
let's see so i should take proof uh
proof data set
or what
whatever
okay all right okay
well i can't tell what those lemmas are
let's let's let's show the um
you can just hover over them
i did i know i know i can hover over
them but then i hover over one and then
i hover over the other and i can't see
them both together
um
okay
so
substitution number one
what
i'm so confused the
this is
this is the simplest non-trivial case of
something like this right where you've
got you've just got an expression of
commutativity and then you've got a
you've got a function which is
nested to recursion depth too
so there are
yeah
so within that sub-expression there are
two places you could apply on on the
first level and there's a there's one
place you can apply it on the outer
level
yes and the point is substitution number
one and substitution number two have
non-overlapping part specifications
so their order is
i see because they're they're applying
themselves to
expressions they have non-overlapping
part specifications but that information
is not encoded in the structure of the
proof graph
whereas if you were to construct a
global multi-wave representation of it
as one can do for instance for for
combat
for a combinator calculus then it
becomes obvious that when that's
happening because every
state vertex here is a sub-expression
and the causal relations expressed
precisely when those sub-expressions are
shared and when they're not all right so
let's let's go glocal here what should
we try which which example should we try
uh
i mean the first is
simple it's just a fixed point
combinator but it probably illustrates
what needs to be illustrated
okay
okay
ah that's because we defined f i thought
that was going to happen to us
okay
oh my
all right let's try to understand this
what's
this is compressed because uh token
deduplication is enabled by default but
so all that's saying is
that you know the event on the left
there which takes in y y of f and
outputs y of f y y of f
is ingesting two tokens of the form y
and one token of the format f and
outputting whatever it is three tokens
of the form y and two tokens of the
format
and each one of those in each one of
those arrows is tagged with part
specification information just like it
is in find equation proof and so then
looking to see whether there are
overlapping sub expressions or not is
how we determine
whether there are causal relations or
not
okay for people who are not as familiar
looking at this let me try explaining
this
okay so this is an event
the event has certain
is like a function that has certain
inputs in this case it has two y tokens
and an f token that happen to be
arranged in this tree structure
and
then there is a rule coming from outside
this universe here so to speak
that is what defines this event
and it
produces this thing which is y of f of y
of y of f
which then
whose elements
there are three y's there
and they get used in this token y here
because there isn't token do
token deduplication is not on if token
deduplication was on
this would be more dag-like and that y
there would be the same as that y there
is that correct
jonathan is that right so that there's
there are multiple levels of token
deduplication but yeah you know in
effect if it were maximally deduplicated
um there would only be one y in the
system
right right exactly so you and you could
see that if you if you switch the option
duplicate tokens to true you will see
that
i have a very bad feeling this picture
is going to become even more obscure
it's they're very hard to read when
they're deduplicated
now the deduplicated version is very
similar to a patreon is that a true
statement
yes uh so in fact it's um in the for the
um
graph rewriting case it's precisely
it
one reproduces precisely the execution
semantics of a petrinet
for type graphs
okay
so i i just wanna we have multiple
people here who have different expertise
like for example i'm gonna pick on
somebody like roger are you
understanding at all what the heck we're
talking about here
no i'm sorry i was
answering an email right now so no not
this one
okay i think this is relevant to you
since you understand petri nets and
things um right
okay
let's well okay
okay but but
the point here
as
okay what we're trying to discuss is
what is an evaluation graph
for
our language
okay what is it how what is the best
representation of the evaluation process
as a graph
okay and the the representations we have
so far
are the trace representation which loses
tons of information because in
particular the trace representation
doesn't tell us
it tells us what the output of every of
every transformation is but it doesn't
tell us
how the transformation was made
right it doesn't give bindings for the
pattern variables it doesn't give
positions where replacements were made
it doesn't give any of that information
so when you teach it you have to give a
model to the user right so the classical
model is the substitution model of
evaluation
and that is equivalent to basically an
animated graph a graph that sort of
changes over time
right
you know and no it's no no that's
completely unobvious to me
that's completely unobvious because
remember
one of the key things
let's say did you have f of x comma y
and you substitute in an expression for
x now that x becomes a sort of a tree
you know like an in itself a little
graph
okay so what you're proposing there what
you're saying which i don't i mean i
think that's
i believe that's an obscure way to think
about it but we can we can we can
go down this route for a second okay
in fact we've we've never made these
pictures even for combinators
of
clearly with combinators
as you evaluate the combinator tree
you will get maybe we could trivially
make this with ian's tree stuff
um
but what i was going to say
you had
at some point earlier you showed a case
where each node was itself a graph
and so there's nothing that says that
you couldn't put that animated graph
into a giant super graph where all the
nodes are graphs
sure
no that's exactly what i mean that's
what we're doing
for example when we make these multi-way
graphs of graph rewriting systems
right that's the global multi-way graph
jonathan has these global ones we also
have local multi-race systems where
where what's happening is
you are
the problem with a global multi-way
system like that
is there's lots of redundancy because
you have the whole graph and you show a
new state of the whole graph but
actually only a tiny piece of the graph
changed
right
so you're making a copy i mean it's like
saying
uh
you know it's like doing a
replace
on a giant expression but only one piece
of the expression is being replaced
but yet you're showing the whole
expression again now yes in
implementationally
it is not so expensive because it is
very daggified you know there are common
pointers and things there
but serialized in the language it is
extremely long
yeah
right so
i mean the the thing we're trying to do
and the thing that i think is super
difficult
is
the trade-off between you have an object
that you can pick up and hold and
and and so on
that is a global thing
where you have a lot of
of of um redundancy
versus the thing has been smashed into
pieces every piece is unique
but you don't know how the pieces go
together again
is that a i mean jonathan others i mean
is that a reasonable characterization of
kind of the trade-off here
i i think so but can i can i make one
comment in relation to why i think the
the local slash glocal approach
why i think there's merit in seriously
considering that if we're talking about
uh theorem proving in particular
although i suspect it applies more
generally to evaluation in the language
okay
um
very often
you want to form lemmas based on
sub-expressions not based on expressions
right so so right now
when we use a you know a previous lemma
or an axiom or something as a construct
to you know to produce some rule we use
the whole
object right we use the whole construct
yeah but you can imagine you can imagine
having a situation where so you know
suppose you're doing theorem proving
over um
i don't know
boolean algebra or something using the
nand operator and you've got some you've
got two very big complicated
highly nested
nand expressions
which are identical in all of the outer
packaging but in deep nested inside
there's an a nand b and on the right on
the other side there's a b nand a
so the proof of that expression
has implicitly proved the commutativity
of nand but to know that you'd have to
you know peel back all these layers of
packaging and you know find the thing
that's
nested deep inside
so the the the
you know find equational proof which is
in a sense based on a global multi-way
paradigm wouldn't be able to infer
commutativity just based on having
proved that lemma whereas a theorem
based on local or global evolution of
evaluation would
so you're claiming that find equational
proof as it is right now
would
if it had is that in fact something that
happens in the in um in for example the
proof of my axiom and i mean do you know
whether that whether that occurs that's
an interesting case
where
i mean do we know whether that happens i
mean interesting well that was obviously
not for commutativity but there are
certainly cases where there you know
where two expression where one exp two
expressions are proved to be equivalent
where they differ only in
only at the level of one sub-expression
that occurs quite frequently in proofs
that involve
you know well let's let's let's be
specific here okay so let's say um
uh
okay so let's let's just pick up a
bundle of um how can we get this a
bundle of actual relations here um let's
let's do the nand operation for i mean
but commutativity for example so let's
say find equational proof
uh
of
p
center dot q
equals equals
q
center dot p
with that okay so now jonathan how do we
get out the actual series of equalities
and this is by the way another thing
that is an issue is sort of the
extraction of pieces
what what is the we have to dig into
this data set so is it statement what do
we do we say all comma statement
uh yes
within the data set yes
right so proof data set
all comma statement
okay
so now let's say uh values of that
um
okay so now this
and now we're about to use ian so let's
do normal of that
okay
oh my god
look at this creature actually it's not
as bad as i might have thought it's not
as bad as i might have thought okay so
now can we make trees out of these
uh
can we
yeah but i mean i think what we want to
do so the case that jonathan was talking
about is
there are two trees here
which are very similar whose outer
levels are the same so what we want to
do here i think
is to say and i would really like to do
an expression tree where i don't display
any variables and things can i do that
to say trailing a label goes to
all goes to none
okay so
expression tree of that
tree element label
of
all goes to none is that right
yep like this
do i need the brands nope
okay
and then i want to do this mapped at
level two is that right
why is it taking so long oh
okay so there are all of our equations
okay it's kind of interesting that so
many of them have that same left-hand
side by the way already
this helps me in understanding a bit
what the heck is going on
maybe it helps me
i don't know if it really helps me but
but um
because we're looking for other kind of
proof representations okay so
the claim
okay so now how would we tell which of
these have the same
outer levels of that tree
obviously there are variable
i mean so so for example if we look just
at the
the um
uh non-terminal structure of these
things like that one obviously has
a top level that's the same for what
it's worth
is this i mean jonathan is this what you
had in mind
i mean we're asking is there are there
pieces where
i mean and this is
somehow
the
what the heck is it it's
right
so exactly and so the point that i'm
making is that with it with say a global
multi-way evolution
you can trace the you you can trace the
evaluation history of an individual
sub-expression rather than the whole
expression
right and so you can do lemma formation
with a much higher granularity
yeah
okay but but i mean so so an our
evaluator what does it do in terms of
that
i think it does that too because it's
going into sub-expressions to evaluate
them
it doesn't take the whole thing in a big
gulp and do something with it
it goes into the sub expressions to try
and to try and make transformations on
them
so okay so maybe so in the local
multi-way system
here
one of the things that you're doing so
you've got
the tokens you're you're recording
what tokens get get produced
in these computations but you're not
recording
at this level i've just got a bunch of
y's and a bunch of f's in a bag you're
not recording the structure that those
live in
so each each of those edges is invisibly
tagged with essentially a coordinate for
what you know what level of the
expression tree does that particular
token lie at
and though and that that those part
specifications are then what i used to
determine causal relations between the
events
but so
this f
that edge says
this is the two to one part of the
expression is going to be that f
right
now that f is used again
how the heck does it even know
i mean it has to reconstruct itself to
be able to know where it appears in this
event
doesn't it
yeah
is so that's again the trade-off between
you know in a global multi-way system
you've got the whole expression
structure there and you're operating on
you know where everything goes
in this case it's been shattered
and de-duplicated
to some extent
but you don't know where everything goes
so to speak
but what you're saying is these causal
edges
okay
these causal edges are saying that
there is a thing here
that will be used again here so so do
you have so these ones out here
are
causally i'm fairly confused here
you're saying that these different
causal edges represent different
independent parts of that tree
being
consumed in subsequent events is that
right
right
so in a sense
wherever there is a causal edge it is
defining a time-like relation
which is defining something which cannot
be on an anti-chain and therefore cannot
be done separately in parallel by on
different threads
right exactly and that's the thing which
i claim is
again i can't speak to the internal
details of the you know of the evaluator
but at least find equation of proof does
not out of the box support making that
distinction you can infer it from the
part specifications of individual lemmas
but the proof graph itself doesn't
contain that information right so what
you're doing is the stuff
a label there is that some kind of
synchronization event
you can think of it that way yes because
what that's doing is it's having to
collect
the results or something like that yeah
it has to collect the results so far
and do them so so for instance
these two things are completely
independent
they
yes i think you can think of this as a
synchronization event anybody else want
to comment on that
because it's got to collect all the
pieces that go into it
and then do its thing
and unless unless all those pieces have
been correctly assembled it can't run
so it's kind of like a weight
type thing you know
we should we should have had roman in
here as well because this is now his his
kind of world but that's also petra nets
where
they basically
that's those are the preconditions to
make be able to do the next transition
yes but as we were saying here when you
were not paying attention roger of the
the i am
if you de-duplicate all of these tokens
in other words if every
now i'm even more confused i would have
expected okay so if you de-duplicate all
instances of why i thought
that corresponds precisely to a patreon
here but why why are there two why's
here
because they exist on different at
different moments of time
and but is that still in the petrinet
formalism it's still this or do you have
to deduplicate all the way to get to i
don't you have to duplicate all the way
you would have to d if you wanted to get
a true petri now yes
so each token
becomes
essentially a what becomes a token and
each one of these each event becomes a
transition firing
right so roger that's the relationship
between these things okay
um well then i at least in the ballpark
what's that then i mean at least in the
ballpark of that
language that you guys use
right
okay but but so the thing we want
again repeating the thing we're trying
to get to
is a reasonable representation of the
evaluation process
as a graph where we can see causal
relationships between different
uh sort of i mean we can think of the
evaluator as taking a series of actions
some of those and those actions are
events
some of those events are causally
connected to others and some are not for
example in the list you know one plus
one two plus two
the evaluation of one plus one is not
causally connected to the evaluation of
two plus two
but if that whole list is then going to
be ingested later you better have
evaluated both of those things before
you get to the next ingestion point
before you before you before the whole
list is ingested
um
so
and okay so trace
ah it's one corner of this
and i think you guys had it there but i
think it's going to be crucial to not go
too low level
i mean or so to be able to specify what
level you want tracing or graphing to
sort of happen
oh yeah sure because there's a lot of
for all kinds of practical reasons
and theoretical reasons
well trace has a not totally terrible
interface for that yeah
it's clearly sort of some thought of
that right but but i mean and that may
be sufficient to say don't break only
show us
things represent you know correspond to
these patterns now of course that might
be incomplete for the graph
that is
just looking at what happens to those
patterns might not explain what's going
on
if you understand what i'm saying right
evaluating fibonacci it might do fine
but if there was an additional twiddle
where you did some you know secondary
you know gcd computation you wouldn't
see that it would just be a
an oracle so to speak of of delivering a
result
yeah
but then you can kind of drill down
basically at that level right
right so the claim would be it is
explicit things yes okay fair enough and
that and then there are oracle
deliveries
of things where you're not well it's not
explaining why that happens it is just
something that appears
through some mega event or something
right
i'm a little yeah okay but the mega
event the point about our evaluator is
that that mega event must get its input
from something in the evaluation
graph yeah but i think that's super
useful for all of these things we're
talking about like parallelism what is
the granularity of parallelism
or i'm using functions that someone else
wrote you know there's supply chain
someone wrote it i can't really drill
into them
i don't know but i know it's wrong you
know and i pinpointed that's wrong
okay but i think it's useful comments
that the the granularity of parallelism
is the same story
as
i mean okay in most debugging debugging
at different levels of abstraction is
also kind of useful
right but you know in the physics
project unlike the meta mathematics
project by the way but in the physics
project we don't have a lot of hierarchy
that is but didn't you have it in the
metamaths you know didn't uh
um
jonathan talk about sort of um
lemmas or something like that lemmas and
lemma this is all expanded or it's it's
all contracted type thing that's kind of
hierarchy
maybe
maybe maybe you call it something else
but i think well there's a there's a yet
different thing
in studying this metamath database
uh they have this notion of
definitions and
their notion of definitions really does
capture
uh i mean that that is a yet a different
form of hierarchy i probably show you
i'm not sure if i should open this file
because it may be um
ah let me see
um
um
but lemma is like an abstraction right i
don't need to see how you prove dilemma
and i'm just using it it's a different
it's the multiple different kinds of
abstractions sure
a lemma
is a lemma is more like a caching
of a bunch of
okay if you use it like that yes then i
agree that is more like cash
um
it's it's in the same tree but i want to
reuse the state yeah
right
and see if i can open this
but so what i'm saying then is like it's
like like a bigger axiom system i guess
in that context like a much bigger axiom
system
yes i mean so i'm just going to show one
thing if i can find it um
let me see
um
looking for something here
let's see if i can pull it up
okay a more efficient axiom system
right
so
here we go
i've got one
all right this is
from this metamath system
which not to be confused with metal
mathematics
this is a definition hierarchy
okay it's defining plus
ultimately in terms of the operations of
set theory
i see interest
okay so
um i think i have one for yeah here's
one for gcd
um
so it's like what do you have to know
about it's kind of surprising you have
to know about reels here and defining
gcd and maybe the definition isn't right
but in the end you're going down to the
up you know pure operations of set
theory
and
you know you have a more and more
complicated each as you go higher up
here
you're able to package in
more and more but the question is like
wouldn't surprise me if there's an
intermediary level
that you could
i mean i can even see it in this graph
where you don't drill below and i could
say well just use this as a base and i
got myself a plus yeah exactly
right no but as i said i think this is
an orthogonal issue to the issue of
lemmas
i think definitions are an orthogonal
issue dilemmas i think
they're not entirely orthogonal right i
mean they're in a sense they're just
lemmas that you bake in at the beginning
rather than that are generated on the
fly
fair enough
fair enough but they also define terms
they define new terms and things
right but the point is each one of those
operators you know if you write this in
in terms of some predicate calculus or
something each one of those operators is
just going to be
ultimately some quantified equation that
says this composition of expressions
equals this other composition of
expressions with you know with with
different kinds of operators on the left
and right
yes
okay but let's come back okay can do
other people have comments here nick do
you have any comments or well i cannot
say that the definitions can also be
think of it
think of us
disambiguous theorems because when you
you don't have to guide it how to prove
it
you can just parse it
to get its proof
i see
i see i see it doesn't have a
there's no proof chain around it it is
merely a syntactic statement
of this thing being defined it's like a
macro of some kind is that right
oh yeah it's like how you start passing
you usually only have like
one correct way of arriving at the
correct
ast abstract synthetic right
well if you are given a theorem
statement
there is
could be many proofs of
how can i arrive at it
right right but you're coming this is a
rather simple-minded macro language that
is an unambiguous that has an
unambiguous parsing and so on
yeah like metamorphism
yeah right i mean as i understood it
with theorems say in an entailment cone
i mean you're going to get there via
entailment but with a definition
it's a different kind i mean it's being
constructed with a different at a
different level in our framework this is
kind of
or you know
it's at the end level
you know this is such a bizarre and
unfair conversation because we keep on
using these terms
that come out of this project
that are absolutely incomprehensible to
many people
anyway okay yeah but go ahead at least i
understand i think what you're talking
about well the point is that you have to
have this
this tree you have to have this parsing
computation to use the definition once
you have your definitions at least the
way that the metamath language is set up
once you have those then you can get
something like the kind of entailment
cones that we have but it's a kind of a
different it's a computation you have to
do beforehand before you start to have
actual entailment structures or
entailment fabrics that's how i view it
at least
nick right
all right yeah
um
okay so let's see the
uh
so let's come back i mean again
gosh
how to where to go from here
um by the way stephen can i just clarify
something in relation to trace
yeah
so the the example you gave before was
the you know the example where you have
a
computation that bifurcates into you
know where an evaluation bifurcates into
one plus one and two plus one
or two plus two sorry
but it is sorry what i was going to say
was isn't the more relevant case where
it bifurcates into one plus one and two
plus one
where say the right-hand one on each
side came from the is a sub-expression
that came from
a common
previous evaluation
you're saying that will be the case
where they are causally connected
right
uh probably can you give a can can you
see how to make an example because i was
having a hard time
uh you know forming
um
let's see but but
okay
let's again let's review our objectives
one objective is to have a
better
graph
representation okay
the graph representation of find
equational proof
is
says
we're basically taking a a rule
and applying it in the case of find
equation or proof
we're applying it to a rule effectively
or applying an equation to an equation
the more general case is that we're
applying a transformation
to
a
an expression
and so we can view every
every step in the evaluator we can view
as
apply a transformation to an expression
and that transformation might be some
built-in transformation deep in the
internal code of the kernel or it might
be something that we can explicitly see
that a fair statement and so then then
every side effects what's that plus side
effects
yeah side effects are ugly
um
okay so
you know the summary here
is kind of like you know operation of
the evaluator
um
is
each step
you know
oops why is it beeping at me
uh each step
you know
takes
a an expression
a sub-expression
and a transformation
which might be
an explicit
you know
rule
from a colon equals or it
might be inside the kernel
which might also be implemented as a
rule whatever
okay and then and then it returns
then each step
returns
a new sub-expression
and then we have
the meta then
the the the extra piece
is the
is sort of the the motivator the thing
that's doing traversal orders the extra
piece is
where do you go next
aka traversal order and that could be if
we were able to implement to execute in
parallel that could be we do multiple
things next
do we think that's a reasonable summary
of the you know meta summary of the
evaluator
comments from people christopher anybody
well there's also attributes
yeah but that's also that's partly where
do you go next
somewhat controlled by attributes
and what we're not
okay so another another piece
uh you know changing the symbol table
aka
shared
shared pieces
aka
you know dag-like behavior
i think
but so well you don't really see the
dag-like behavior i mean i think the
main thing with the symbol tables just
that's where side effects happen
right
right
i mean we were just talking about
actually in a different discussion on
the subject of dags we were talking
about um
a different topic but it's related to
this infinite data structures
and in which you know that's the x
equals x plus one data structure or the
x equals list x x
where the claim is that instead of those
being expression trees they are
expression dags
maybe they're not even dags are they
just graphs no they're graphs that's why
they that's why they're a problem
i'm i'm so confused expression dags i
think are no problem because those
aren't infinite expression graphs are
where you get infinite expressions
right
i mean isn't it interesting that that we
have
do do you mean that expression x equals
i mean the result the thing that is
produced
okay
i mean you mean an infinite expression
that is a list of itself twice
right now nick has some technology for
this could you maybe put that i've
already lost the um i mean you can do
this as equation solving
and the only solution to those equations
are these infinite expressions
which i'm saying the fixed point
if you're using dana scott's terminology
is basically these infinite expressions
yes
is that dana's terminology did dana that
that anyway who knows there that's
that's his denotational semantics
business well i know that but i didn't
think he anyway well we could ask him
but but
um uh nick were you going to put that
could you put that in the chat or
something the um the the
link to your
um there we go okay thank you
um
so this was a
this is i guess a somewhat toy thing
from nick
of
um
infinite data structures
can you explain
but yeah it's just based on one
constructor
that has a hold argument
and you can and i just defined a bunch
of functions for regular lists that work
on always a list
like map select
like joint
even parallel map
with partition
okay so what is this so this is
a representation so if i say length of
this what will happen
splatteroo okay
so if i say take
ones comma five
okay it didn't happen to work but that
might have worked
you can ask normal of
oh
oh because it didn't so that's another
issue for these infamous things to what
extent does it auto-evaluate does it
auto resolve because clearly it can't
infinitely auto evaluate
you know
right so for an infinite
expression
how much auto evaluation is possible
and what you're saying is you you're
just asking for normal when you know
it's going to be
whatever so you have you can you can
you can apply like oh
five too easy list and that's really
gonna evaluate five times
okay so lazy eval
of take
ones
comma ten let's say and i'm gonna do
that five times
oh that's cool
okay so can i try this with um if i do
my this data structure here will it will
it work or is it hopeless
like one
here you can
make a three two like if you have a
children over three it's going to be a
infinite list always a list you can make
this how do you do that
okay so this one here
you've got fibonacci
and so this is an infinite fibonacci
tree
is that right at least
it's at least
how do i get the
this is a list of
fibonacci numbers the only like
thing here
do you just want x equals
do you just want
what is it x equals cons of x x
you can talk about where is it tree
already it's just not tested properly
yeah
you can
it's funny i have a notebook that's
that's almost exactly the same i mean
this is a this is a classic like lis
pascal
thing
the main the main issue i ran into
though is the fact that it always has to
it unlazily computes the first element
so sometimes there are some things you
can give it where it might take it a
long time to produce the first element
but
yeah
um
is this the uh
okay yeah this is the project
you worked on with luis jonathan so does
this what what did you guys do here so
what what
so
the main thing it was a we implement a
lewis implemented sort of lazy list
evaluation of the standard kind the
place where it gets interesting is then
we essentially define a sort of algebra
on infinite lists
so understanding so when you've got a
generating function
um understanding how those generating
functions compose under things like
unions intersections joins etc
uh proving that lists are equivalent
these all turn out to be actually quite
subtle problems of automated theorem
um
well essentially what you're doing is
you're describing a list by its
generator function
and then you know you can
describe it describe a list by its
generator
yeah in fact this is the classic reason
why one introduces they're improving in
mathematics in a sense
is you describe a list by its generator
and then then can you can you eg prove
two lists are equivalent
right right and so we so we had sort of
toy examples where we could do that or
we where you could prove for instance
that if you joined two infinite lists
together you'd get a different you know
you you get something that's equivalent
to some different important list right
but i mean proving two lists are
equivalent is basically proving that two
expressions are equivalent
which is sort of the classic
problem of find equational proof for
example
the given
you're asking given the evaluation
semantics
are these two things ultimately
equivalent like do they have the same
fixed point
do these two
differently stated generating functions
have the same fixed point
if i'm not mistaken right
but there's also
even without having even without doing
um list equivalents
um you there's still a use for kind of
atp or at least automated expression
simplification just in terms of doing
you know algebraic operations on on
lists
no doubt
yeah
if you take two arbitrary generating
functions and you do you know a join or
a select or cases or something on them
then you're going to get some much in
general some much more horrible
composite generating function but in a
large class that can be simplified
right
i mean roger that is very analogous to
things that we have to do and i mean if
you have an algebraic function and it
describes a solution set
and then you have another
you know you have something which
describes the integers for example
okay you have you have two equations and
isn't this very similar to what we have
to do in algebraic equation
simplification
uh
when you say generating functions do you
mean generating functions or do you mean
something special to lazy construction
not generating functions in the
mathematical sense just literally a
thing that takes in a you know list
index and outputs an element okay
uh
right
so
what i'm saying go ahead
yes i mean
so it's a little difficult but the thing
is that we kind of carefully
we don't entirely we can't avoid sort of
undecidability but we avoid a lot of it
um right it's the same issue here can
you take two
things with a with symbolic
representations for these infinite
structures
and combine them
and and some for some things you we have
many of these
uh well we have
quite a few of these sort of
representations like different holonomic
functions differential roots
okay so
yeah go ahead
they allow you they give you sort of an
implicit
form of generating something infinite
meaning that you know an infinite power
series for it
meaning you know an
infinite precision evaluation for it
same with roots they're implicit but you
really you can start you can evaluate
your heart's content as far out as you
want
indeed
so you see this this thing with these
lazy infinite structures
somehow that reminds me of traversal
orders
in evaluation which reminds me of the
thing you were saying roger
about you know how far down do you go
into the weeds
by the way with the cons list things i
mean that's that's sort of exactly
traversal order because again the whole
point is just that i mean this cons here
is just it's just
there's nothing special about just a
symbol with the attribute hold rest
right
and so in what sense does that define
traversal order
well i mean basically you're telling it
to
know what to do next
yeah you're telling it not to to
traverse down the right hand side
because you'll you'll get lost forever i
mean instead you just you know you do
the left hand side and then you you know
yeah
um
i think we're hearing lots of word
background noise but um
we are unfortunately we're quite over
time and i realized that we had jeremy
here because we were going to talk about
the graphical appearance of of um
uh
of automated
of find equational proof output which we
have not managed to do because we're you
know in the end we're going to have i
think a master appearance for
the
you know i think this is going to be the
same as an evaluation graph because i
think it's going to be the about
unless i'm unless i'm totally confused
this will be the evaluation graph
for
the proof function is that true or am i
confused here
anybody have an opinion about that
jonathan do you have an opinion about it
yeah i think
yeah
so
i mean
go ahead
modulo the usual subtleties that we kind
of discussed yesterday
yes
i mean yes
and i mean this question about their
variables being defined and those are in
your proof function right now how what
does your proof function look like right
now your proof function
for example
for instance only check substitution
lemmas
um
as jose was mentioning yesterday it
doesn't uh
we never found a nice representation for
critical pair lemmas although
i just never got around to implementing
it but so wait a minute so so what
you're saying is a substitution llama is
a straightforward replace act is that
correct
yes uh yeah or
internally we implement it as a map of
replace yeah that's what i meant there
isn't a replace that yeah um
okay so that's the substitution lemma go
ahead
though arguably there should
be yes
arguably that should be replaceable was
approved in ild or am i misremembering
i think it was i'm not i'm okay if it
wasn't avery can go chase that and see
whether
um
so
okay so critical pairs aka by
substitution aka whatever
that appears to be much more relevant
when you are
operating on patterns which is again a
thing we are not doing language wise we
don't have a lot of you know there are
two types of things we don't have we
don't have things that opera well many
types of things we don't have we don't
have things that operate on patterns we
don't have a lot of functions that
operate on patterns that eat patterns
and produce other things
and i suspect that's what
a critical pair lemma naturally does i
suspect naturally that it's maybe nick
can you comment on this i mean you you
now have a function that essentially is
a critical pair lemma is that right
yeah
it's a it's a by substitution on rules
that's my interpretation
right but so whereas a substitution
is a pure
sort of
structural substitution on something
which might happen to be a rule
a by substitution is a specific kind of
operation
that
operates on something which has patent
variables in it
it's not interesting unless it has
patent variables in it the true
statement
well if it if there is no patent
variable then it's just substitution
because it
completely
mimics the substitution case also with
some extra
people
yeah right okay so
sorry as i was trying to articulate
yesterday there is a very important
subtlety though which is that unlike for
substitutions in a critical pair lemma
the input can be sort of generated
x nihilo if that makes sense
sorry say that again well it means with
ordinary substitutions right you've got
an input you apply a rule that's derived
from some construct you get an output
right it's clear where the input comes
from it comes from somewhere else in the
proof graph
with a critical parallel that that
doesn't need to be the case it often is
but not it's not necessarily true
no it's like if you have
two
uh inputs
to a critical pi dammer that's all
information you need in order to
reconstruct the output
of course
but the point is the input doesn't need
to have been an expression that was
previously defined it can just be an
arbitrary expression it doesn't need to
have come from anywhere sure just like
the in a substitution the rule that's
being applied
could just be sprinkled in from nowhere
it doesn't have to that rule in
yeah
accept it except the rule is derived
from axioms
the point is okay okay all right well
the common sub-expression that appears
in the critical polymer is the only
thing in this entire proof graph that
doesn't necessarily need to have come
from anywhere it just needs to exist
abstractly it's a common sub-expression
it's a sub-expression over some of the
inputs it's always the case in the proof
graph i haven't seen an exception to
that
jonathan do you want to comment on that
that that where the
you're saying jonathan is saying
a critical pair lemma could just be
consider the random expression blah blah
blah
now notice that but but the thing is
that the now notice that
that that is a common sub-expression of
these two things that are coming in
you're not going to have create it's
irrelevant it's free-floating unless
there are things unless there are a pair
of things coming in to which this
critical pair correspondence can be
applied is that right
right but the point is
i'm sorry go on
well yeah it's like if you have two
inputs you can you have multiple ways to
unify sub-expressions of those two
inputs
and as soon as you pick the position
where
where the unification
will be happening that's it you can
just make a by substitution and that's
the result of your critical problem
my question is
based on what nick is saying
with bi substitution or cubs
co-substitution as involving these
sub-expressions i don't see how
i don't see how that's x nilo
because you're still going to be working
with whatever you had before
you're just
working on sub-expressions of them as
opposed to what you would do with
substitution
i think jonathan is i think what
jonathan means
is
you could just say consider this
expression
but that expression i claim will be
untethered unless it appears as a
sub-expression of the things that are
coming in
or am i confused
look i mean
okay
jonathan any any thoughts about that
yeah so the the the point is that the
operation from
by which you obtain the critical pair
from the inputs of the you know the
rules that went in all the constructs
that went in
involves taking a context and then doing
a you know and then doing a matching
using most general unifiers all of which
is not going to preserve the structure
of the input
so you can end up with outputs that will
then match some future pattern which is
why you produce the lemma in the first
place but the
common sub-expression to which you
applied the rules doesn't need to have
come from anywhere previously
i think i understand i'm not sure i
fully understand this isn't it going to
be the left-hand side of your machine
construct
it's like
it'll be derived from that yes sure yeah
but the point is you you
there are many different ways that you
could unify it
yeah but do you like that's the point of
proof you have to find a way
but as soon as you're given a matching
construct in the position where the
unification happens
that's all the information you need
no i i i don't disagree with any of this
i i'm merely making the point that in
all other aspects of a proof graph
when you apply
you know a a
construct where one side is a pattern
and the other side is not a pattern
the the you know the binding of the
pattern terms to actual concrete
expressions is already known with a
critical parallel it's only known after
the substitution's already been applied
after unification
after unification yes
so you just have to
you just have to repeat the invocation i
think you i think you're probably saying
the same thing just in slightly
different ways i think so too because
nick has this you know he is this new
substitution co-substitution approach
but it sounds like if i understand what
jonathan is saying and what nick is
saying what nick is saying is you're
basically doing it on sub expressions
what jonathan is saying is yeah but when
you do that you get something
that you you wouldn't have seen before
had you not um
no you're not doing it on sub
expressions james you're doing it on sub
patterns
and then the output involves concrete
expressions
right that is the nature which i finally
more or less understood of
co-substitution where you need to where
you are
instancing the operand rather than the
operator so to speak
i think we're getting into a deep rat
hole here but i do think that there's a
i mean the meta point here is that there
may be a bunch of natural operations
including some that nick has been
looking at recently on pattern
expressions that we've never had
because we've never really manipulated
pattern expressions pattern expressions
have always been the thing coming in
that does stuff to something else
rather than expressions that we
manipulate so i i suspect there's a
project that needs to be done that is
you know functions for manipulating
pattern expressions
um
and i think manipulating both patterns
and functions
um we've done this many times in the
past something that was kind of dead
meat just for evaluation like graphics
primitives and they've become alive you
know you can manipulate them you can do
all kinds of things around them
and
you know if it would be fun you know
then we can really do
you know maybe easier to do meta
programming mean you know generating
functions basically from all kinds of
functions okay so you're saying this is
you know functions that manipulate
pure functions basically
yeah
would you know create functions generate
functions transform functions no you're
right i mean and then
the other thing that we were just
talking about in another discussion
recently was function
which obviously the compiler folks do
one in very important aspects of but i
think it's
broader than that
right
i mean like for example we don't even
have a function that renames
the dummy variables in functions
i mean that's a very elementary thing eg
you know renaming slash canonicalizing
uh
you know dummy variables
in function in nested functions
now that's analogous to like jose's
tensor manipulation i think
what's the analogy between
boy we're zipping around between so many
different areas but what's the analogy
between a dummy index and a tensor
and
a bound variable and a function
they have to be very sensor in the
tensor we worry only about two
constructs table and some
well here this is more general
okay fair point
third point
go ahead
we found
that you know we we do some of this meta
manipulation but in a more kind of
mathematical part of the system so we
have basically scoped variables but
they're not scoped in the core
programming language sense of function
so laplace transform has a first ver you
know a personal function of x
x comma s that x is scoped right which
is what i'm saying it's not a free x
yep well with integrate or something
like that yes
but it's but it's sitting there like
let's say that you have an inactive
laplace transform that x is scoped it's
not free i see
you're right and this question if you
have nested laplace transforms you can
potentially be totally screwed because
because you've got conflicting x's
yeah and early on we found out that sort
of some
some functions
and this is this is more to be done
because there's this there's a lot of
theorems to be developed but for
instance when you differentiated that
thing with respect to x it would it
would literally differentiate it if it
was a function of x
right i mean because we've got laplace
transform here we can make it super
confusing we could do comma
a comma c here
and then what the heck does that mean
yeah we'll take that first thing and
differentiate it with respect to a
that you know
so
well differentiation is a very ugly i
mean differentiation is kind of
committing you
to we've we fixed that but the early
version i'm just saying that they're
more of these things of interactions
it's just like not right not captured
well i know but this also relates to
another big complicated thing that we've
been talking about what is a variable
formal variables and so on because a
formal variable among other things is a
variable whose name would has to have a
definite name but it doesn't matter what
that name is
correct
which is again closely related to
vertices and graphs which have that same
property
but you don't really care what the names
of the vertices are for the purpose of
you know thinking about it as a graph
right
well i think if that it's just space i
think that it's actually very practical
to be able to generate
and to some extent transform functions
because that's
you know you can generate code you can
do all kinds of things
no i agree i agree so this is a look we
just had a good meeting a few weeks ago
on held expressions and i believe to
somebody remember what we generated we
generated a bunch of functions that we
want for manipulating health expressions
and this is a another case actually sort
of a special case of that is
manipulating functions
and yet a different case is manipulating
pattern expressions
you know it is fun it's a whole bunch of
stuff but by the way i mean there's a
whole bunch of stuff
you know this is this is kind of a can
of worms but there's a whole bunch of
stuff with like
um
you know there's a lot of automatic
stuff that happens with for example if
you have nested modules or if you have
modules inside of functions or functions
inside of modules etc and basically the
their name collisions or or when you
have a uh you know
uh of a hold all function containing a
module where it inserts its arguments
into the module and then the module
variables get automatically renamed etc
etc there's a lot of stuff like this
that we kind of do automatically but
where
there's sort of uh i mean they're
various kinds of nice
programming language things you can you
know weird functional things you can do
if that stuff didn't happen
um
but uh
yes i mean the fact that inserting into
a function
you know or inserting into a module
changes names
is usually the right thing but some i
mean it feels like we need something
analogous to splice
meaning don't change the name when we do
the insertion
yeah like there are several places this
happens with module it happens with the
function does it as well you know if you
have a function that's that
like i mean it doesn't even have to be
hold alt if you have a function that
takes another function as its argument
you know there there's certain
yeah right i mean
here here's an example of something
that so we have a function that's called
discrete shift
and discrete difference or difference
delta
and that's basically a substitution if
substitution knew about scoping which it
doesn't
right which i'm saying
so
so
can somebody just give the the minimal
example for the name change in the
functions what happens here if i say
function of a a plus one
and then say comma for the third
argument just say hold all i mean that
this will
almost certainly work
um but but maybe maybe in the function
or um
hold on i was thinking of an example of
module actually
because someone else knows an example of
function
but if i just do slash dot a goes to b
what will it do
nothing much
um
well if you put another function outside
of that function it will rename with
also with the variable a
it will um
i think it will change one of them to a
dollar sign
i mean it'll scope it correctly but i
mean change one of the dollar sign try
it
oh never mind used well it turns it red
um try okay yeah
if you want an example of one type of
mangling not just the function you can
do the thing with
if you have a
hold all function containing a module
and you insert something into that
module
i think it i think it mangles the module
variables
right
oh leonard wrote something
about metal programming
okay
um
huh well we should study this
maybe else clearing it about it
um
seems like leonard should be involved
both leonard and roman are relevant to
different aspects of what we're talking
about here
all right we should wrap up um
uh many different directions here but i
would say that the
you know
these are definitely things to look at
and
it seems like the the sort of the big
the the elephant problem here
is can we make a evaluation graph
for the language and if we could do that
we could clean up trace
we could potentially have a nice way of
having something where the fragments of
that you know where we could use that
graph
for find equation or proof
and we would be able to take and the the
real the real thing that would make that
graph useful is that there you could
take fragments out of that graph and
they would still be meaningful i believe
um
okay actually i've got a general comment
about that
um
this is actually this is an interesting
way to think about it uh okay for one
feature of any expression in our
language is you can always take a sub
expression and you can still hold it in
your hand so to speak it's it's still an
expression every sub-expression is an
expression
but for the evaluation graph it is not
obvious that every subgraph of the
evaluation graph is an evaluation graph
is it
maybe there's a way to formulate it so
that it is
i think if you think of it as a partial
order thing
then you can't take any subgraph because
that's too arbitrary probably
okay it has to hang together in some way
i know but that's that's the point so
every every sub expression is still an
expression
is
but the sub-expression the
sub-expression is like a sub-tree you
know and if they're dag it's a sub-dag i
know yeah right so that's probably the
analog
well but but but i mean
see because because that would allow one
i mean this is okay so long long ago
i had this idea
that actually bruce smith was much
involved with also which was could you
represent a looping program and so on
just by giving it's
it's kind of like the analog of visual
programming but with greater generality
where you could say here is this
representation of an execution history
of a program represented as a graph
now i can just put it together with
other graphs and that defines as a
symbolic thing execution history instead
of having a loop where you know program
counters are changing if that makes
sense
it's kind of like how net graph works
but you can't really have loops i don't
think
yes it is it's like it's like how a
visual programming you know it it would
be the ultimate sort of visual
programming story if one could take an
evaluation graph and fit it together
kind of lego style
that would be
like a visual programming system
yes
i mean i think that's correct
sorry go ahead now go ahead
i was thinking that is actually how
scratching these other things do isn't
it
yeah but they have a very simple i mean
they're
and they do not have the property that
every subgraph of their evaluation graph
is an evaluation graph
okay uh
sorry
go ahead
no i was just going to say so i think
it's so the condition is not that every
sub graph is an evaluation of an
evaluation graph as an evaluation graph
i think what you need to impose is
something that is quite analogous to
what in graph transformation theory is
called the convexity condition where you
want the you want it to be the case that
whatever subgraph you have
it must satisfy the property that any
vertex that doesn't lie on the initial
layer
doesn't you're not when you take that
when you take the subgraph you're not
severing any incoming edges
in other words
in components to all vertices that lie
off the initial layer are preserved
under the action of taking the subgraph
um
that sounds right
that's what i had in mind also if you
think of that the partial order i mean
sort of the tag
right right
that appears naturally when you're doing
uh when you're doing graph unfoldings
and you want to take sub-evaluations of
graph unfoldings um and yeah it's a
pretty general condition
okay i didn't completely i understand
the general concept of it but
the basic idea is you shouldn't you know
your your computation shouldn't be you
your evaluation shouldn't be using
dependencies that don't lie in the
subgraph i see i see i see don't don't
use
don't use things that aren't defined in
the subgraph right so your initial layer
you're allowed to just
generate that kind of from nowhere but
everything
everything subsequent to the initial
layer should only use things that are
inside the subgraph so you shouldn't so
none of those vertices should have in
components that are changed by taking
the subgraph
right
the out components can do whatever they
want but the in components have to
remain the same right but i mean it's
like when you disembodied the thing it
cannot be the case because the
evaluation graph has a notion of time
whereas sub-expressions do not have a
notion of time so you can pick up any
sub-expression and it's a meaningful
thing it just sings and dances on its
own so to speak
but as soon as it's in an evaluation
graph there can be
you know it's like i don't know what
that is unless
i got it from a previous state is that a
fair fair assessment
oh it's a piece of the graph is simply
not defined unless
whereas an expression it is what it is
there's no
it didn't have to be created
in an
evaluation graph
things had to be created and if you
maybe there's a way of cauterizing it of
saying this is
i mean like in sort of some general
relativity kind of thing this is the
thing that's coming in
from um
uh
you know i don't know past infinity or
something some something that's just
arriving
like you were talking about the initial
layer just arriving you're saying you
can't guarantee that something not on
the initial layer is well-formed if it
didn't come if it wasn't created by
something is that a fair
characterization
yeah yeah something like that
but you could imagine preparing
something
that
you could imagine sort of
ex machina
um no that's a really bad and that's
really bad for what we're doing i mean
for from
you know it could have just existed at
the beginning of the universe type thing
you could so long as it is well formed
it's okay to just plug it into the graph
even later on it's just that you don't
anticipate that it will be well formed
the true statement i mean there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
plugging in an intermediate expression
that you didn't in fact get that's a
fake intermediate expression that you
didn't get by actually constructing it
so long as it is correctly formed i
believe you can do that
unless maybe it's
go ahead
well maybe for talking when graphs it's
easier to imagine it's like preserve the
events
only the inputs for events you can drop
any output but the inputs to the unc
always preserve all of them
well you're saying because otherwise the
causal relationships don't work and so
on
um
the uh
um
right we should wrap up here this is a
this is oh tony just said oh
tony we didn't know tony was here but
tony just sent a an example of um
the uh
of the problem
okay
so
what the heck is this okay x blank goes
to function
hey
i see
yes okay that's where it has to rename
so so that reminded me of rdf and
sparkle where there are so called blank
nodes
those are nodes which can't be
referenced by definition from the
outside now so this goes in the
direction of
pure
formal variables
i see okay so this is
um
jonathan you're just commenting about
expression manipulation internally in
the theorem proving framework for
quantifiers what's that about
so i think that implicitly when we give
a variable or pattern variable we think
of it as for all
right right so the point is that the
theorem prover treats any any
universally quantified variable as a
pattern exactly as roger said and vice
versa when you're dealing with patterns
and constructs when you translate them
back into statements we put universal
quantifiers around them with the
appropriate scoping
and so there's already in a sense
there's already functionality in the
theorem proving framework for
doing some manipulation of pattern
expressions for converting
pattern expressions from the expressions
and doing things like you know
golemization or changing bound variables
or whatever
um
and then as you mentioned so so dummy
variables or dummy indices in tensors or
something that's a special case of that
where instead of just universally
quantifying you are your summing
um yeah they're both quantifiers sum is
basically a quantifier right exactly but
it's yeah
as i mentioned it's a special case of
the above you know it is quite
head-spinning how much uh sort of how
many common themes there are between all
these different areas
really remarkable and we are you know
that that's where
you know in the in the whole language
design thing this is where we'll get if
we can figure out this evaluation graph
thing there's going to be amazing power
from that and if we can get because that
is the next
that's sort of a you know it's a meta
level
of um
uh
um
yeah of all this stuff
uh of i mean you know
it is the more dynamic version of
okay the thing we have never met our
eyes
no we have never made symbolic
is the process of evaluation so to speak
we've made symbolic so many things in
our system but the process of evaluation
is has not been made properly symbolic
and this what this is about is making
symbolic the process of evaluation i
think
which is something which
in a sense in the physics project
a lot of what we can think about that is
doing
is making an actual structure that is
the structure of space time et cetera et
cetera et cetera that is a
representation of an evaluation process
whereas
yeah and um
anyway okay very interesting stuff well
look um
thanks a lot everybody and uh
we will continue this and um try and i
think maybe i mean i felt like this was
a
i mean although we went through various
different areas here i thought this was
a somewhat coherent meeting i don't know
how other people felt about it but i
think we're making
we're making progress and um
know if anybody can think about this
evaluation graph question that would be
really nice
um
any last comments
okay
sounds good